in the searing heat of the californian
desert
there's a strange migration taking place
a pilgrimage for people with the same
problem
they need to get their teeth fixed
but they can't afford it at home
we're crossing the border with them
just a short walk and we're in mexico
into a town of around 6 000 people and
yet 600 of them are dentists giving
americans what their own country can't
seem to
they call this the dental capital of the
world
welcome to molar city
thank you for coming so no pain a lot to
gain all right
let's start making that taking an extra
promoters are pitching competition is
brisk are you checking prices i need a
tooth taken care of all right look
there's no doctor come on in no waiting
let's go let's go
almost free i'm pablo by the way
los algodones is improving the mouths of
thousands of americans
the price difference is
ridiculous i've had other work done here
in the past and i'd probably save twenty
thousand dollars two thousand dollars
out of pocket in the states compared to
four hundred here is a big difference
especially because i have five kids so
everybody is legit you've got you've got
new equipment you've got clean
procedures
why would you not come
i make minimum wage and i can't afford
insurance
dana kennedy is one of the 140 million
people in the us without dental
insurance
ow
which way this way
all right i won't cry i promise
she needs emergency care but she's
crossed into another country to get it
you're an excellent patient
oral health was long seen as a luxury
state site and cutting costs isn't a top
priority of either political party it is
a shame
because america is supposed to be
one of the best countries in the world
and
it depends on
your economic standard
where are you getting your materials
from
uh we get them from uh imported from the
states
so you have american patients correct
american materials we use the same
products that they will use on the
states for our
services
most of the patients we spoke to voted
for donald trump
undeterred by his warnings about mexican
drug dealers and rapists
many of the clinics treating them hire
deportees
it's an irony not lost on a place that's
flourished because their wealthy
neighbor puts a high price on the cost
of a healthy smile
cordelia lynch sky news los algodones
mexico